bonsoir et bienvenue pour le journal de
tv fit l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
18h du lundi au vendredi aujourd'hui 15
janvier il sera question de la
mobilisation au tribunal de commerce son
président s'est montré ferme en début de
semaine en rappelant que leur activité
pourrait s'arrêter à tout moment si le
gouvernement ne revoie pas son projet de
réforme principale opposition
l'introduction des magistrats
professionnels à côté des juges
bénévoles les voeux du président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines après une année marquée par
les difficultés budgétaires 2015
pourrait-elle permettre de se relancer
les finances sont en tout cas c'est ni
annonce son président et puis je reçois
ce soir pascal rodier président du
secours populaire des yvelines nous
reviendrons notamment sur les besoins de
bénévoles pour mener à bien leurs
missions au camp de satory aversa et
jean yves le drian le ministre de la
défense a accueilli ce matin les
militaires déployés pour le plan
vigipirate depuis l'attaqué meurtrière
contre ces journalistes dessinateur
caricaturiste de charlie hebdo le 7
janvier le plan a été relevé au niveau
alerte attentes à 6 mille militaires
sont dispersés en ile de france pour une
durée de trois semaines environ yolaine
thorez elodie - 11h30 ce matin le
ministre de la défense arrive sur le
camp de satory à versailles jean yves le
drian est venu accueillir les militaires
envoyés en ile de france pour participer
au plan vigipirate alerte attentats
habitués a activé la cellule le 14
juillet pour accueillir chaque année les
centaines de soldats pour le défilé
c'est aussi ici à satory quête assurer
la grande partie de l'hébergement de
l'alimentation de l'équipement et du
transport des 6000 militaires déployés
pour l'occasion en ile-de-france un
déploiement jugé très rapide par le
ministre le contrat opérationnel de
protection est inscrit dans la loi de
programmation prévoyait après la
décision du présent de rabut mais qu'il
y ait une semaine de mobilisation pour
atteindre le chiffre de 2
mille hommes on l'a fait en trois jours
vous l'avez fait en trois jours les
militaires l'ont fait en trois jours
dont c'est une réactivité tout à fait
remarquable accompagné de jean pierre
raffarin président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense du
sénat
le ministre salue ces militaires arrivés
quelques heures plus tôt ce matin dans
des salles réquisitionnées pour la
distribution et les militaires c'est
qu'ils paient encore et gilet
pare-balles tenue casque gants à livrer
au fur et à mesure ces militaires seront
ensuite dispersées dans toute
l'ile-de-france dès à présent les sites
sensibles sont protégées par deux les
militaires en bonne articulation avec
les forces de police et des forces de
gendarmerie pour assurer la sécurité
notre pays face aux menaces qui sont
maintenus au total sur l'ensemble du
territoire national dix mille cinq cents
militaires sont déployés
la visite aura duré un peu plus d'une
heure elle se termine par l'hymne de
national en décembre dernier les
tribunaux de commerce suspendaient leurs
audiences la raison de cette colère la
loi macron après le retrait de certains
des articles les audiences ont repris
mme ont repris mais la colère est
toujours là mélanie poker william l ils
ont tous obtenu des avancées mais il ne
baisse pas les bras
ils ce sont les 134 tribunaux de
commerce
il reproche à la loi macron de vouloir
délocaliser certains dossiers dans
d'autres tribunaux les dossiers seraient
renvoyés devant des tribunaux de
commerce
ils ont plus important que le ministère
estime avoir les compétences nécessaires
1 quitte à ce que dans un deuxième temps
en sommes convaincus c'est fameux
tribunaux de références soient eux-mêmes
échevine et c'est à dire que l'on
introduirait dans ces formations de
jugement des tribunaux de référence des
magistrats professionnels
ces mesures sont des mesures
défiance à l'encontre de l'institution
consulaire
cette mesure de référence est totalement
injustifiée au tribunal de commerce les
juges sont bénévoles élus par leurs
pairs ils sont commerçants entrepreneurs
ou dirigeants d'entreprises
ils suivent une formation à l'école
nationale de la magistrature la loi
nacre on ferait notamment intervenir des
magistrats professionnels
si ce projet de loi est présenté à
l'assemblée nationale avec l'article sur
la spécialisation automatique des
tribunaux de commerce
il est très clair que les tribunaux de
commerce dans leur totalité reprendront
le mouvement qui avait été interrompue
mais qui tend à la suspension totale de
l'activité juridictionnelle
le tribunal de versailles a rendu plus
de 14500 décision pour l'année 2014
c'est 33 % de plus qu'en 2013 la loi
doit être présenté à l'assemblée
nationale pour un débat public à partir
du 26 janvier
jean paul huchon candidat aux élections
régionales de 2015 l'actuel patron de
l'île de france va tenter de décrocher
un quatrième mandat à la fin de l'année
il devra néanmoins passer le cap des
primaires sa vice présidente marie
pierre de la gontrie ayant aussi fait
acte de candidature cette dernière
d'ores et déjà soutenu publiquement par
la maire de paris anne hidalgo dans
l'opposition valérie pécresse député des
yvelines est en bonne place à l'ump pour
remporter l'investiture
que réserve 2015 à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines son
président a livré quelques indices
aujourd'hui lors de sa cérémonie de
voeux
catherine gélato plus serein c'est ainsi
que jean luc baissière résume son état
d'esprit devant la communauté
universitaire il faut dire que le budget
initial 2015 vient d'être votée en
conseil d'administration
un budget en équilibre sans aide
exceptionnelle de l'état au contraire de
les économies ont été trouvées pour
permettre de nouveaux investissements
on est dans la dynamique voire une
dynamique plutôt positive puisqu'on peut
mettre plus de crédit fonctionnement
travail peut remettre en 2014 donc c'est
peut-être pas encore le bonheur le
paradis mais
on a pu multiplier par deux les
fonctionnements 18 fr les laboratoires
qui est un autre signe intéressant c'est
qu'on
on offre des emplois un recrutement
alors qu'elle dernière n'avait pas être
anodine qu'elle n'avait pas eu de
recrutement
donc voilà on recrute donc des
enseignants-chercheurs également des
personnes admiratif ingénieurs
techniques allant par un nombre
mirifiques un don byas très emplois
d'enseignants et il ya quinze bus 10 + 3
28 emplois de personnes administratif et
pour prouver que malgré les difficultés
de 2014 et les chercheurs ont montré
leur savoir faire
l'université a souhaité les mettre à
l'honneur parmi eux philippe bousquet
nommé à l'institut universitaire de
france
le chercheur travaille sur le gaz
méthane et la compréhension de
l'évolution de ce gaz à effet de serre
pour le changement climatique
une recherche qui compte alors que la
france va accueillir en novembre
prochain la conférence internationale
sur le climat
si on comprend aujourd'hui comment
fonctionne le métal on à être capable
peut-être de se projeter dans l'avenir
or aujourd'hui on ne comprend pas très
bien et beaucoup d'incertitudes c'est le
travail des scientifiques peuvent donner
après aux politiques des chiffres de
plus en plus précis voilà des choses de
moins en moins certaine je n'avais pas
de certaines parce qu'il ya jamais de
certitudes absolues pour que le positif
puisqu'on est décisions adaptées
en fait voilà ce que nous on trouve
aujourd'hui un laboratoire très souvent
mises à l'honneur et qui va prendre
encore plus d'importance alors que lui
vs que bien intégré officiellement au 31
décembre l'université de paris saclay
qui regroupe 19 établissements
prestigieux
le président du secours populaire des
yvelines est l'invité de ce journal
bonfort pascal rodier et bienvenue vous
venez ce soir pour évoquer cette grande
mobilisation 17 24 janvier deux journées
de collecte pour aider les familles qui
font appel à vous comment vont se
dérouler ces collectes tout d'abord
alors en fait c'est dans le cadre d'un
partenariat national qui se décline sur
le département avec l'ancien carrefour
et carrefour market nous fait un appel
aux bénévoles et à la générosité du
public par le biais de ces fameux
bénévoles à la sortie des magasins je
pense que tout le monde connaît un petit
peu le concept on appelle ça
vulgairement des opérations chariots
donc là la petite nouveauté c'est que en
fait il ya un groupement de conserverie
qui a édité les produits partage et on
va inviter les gens à cibler un petit
peu plus sur ces produits est comme ça
ça permet de faire d'une pierre deux
coups
répondre à un besoin matériel et en même
temps de contribuer indirectement au
financement de nos actions par le
reversement des produits donc c'est
constamment collecte alimentaire non pas
uniquement si si si c'est que
alimentaire ce ne sont que des produits
alimentaires quels sont les besoins
spécifiques et alimentaires juste avant
la plupart du temps c'est des produits
les produits secs comme je disais en
conserverie donc c'est ça permet de
faire des repas qui sont duplicable en
termes de en termes de durée de vie des
produits
c'est beaucoup plus intéressante du
frais c'est beaucoup moins contraignant
pour les structures et puis ça permet de
couvrir la palette large des besoins des
familles du petit déjeuner au repas
essentiel de la journée donc les
personnes seront amenés en fait nous
aider sur le même principe que
d'habitude produits petit déjeuner
conserves etc
mais avec cette petite 1,6 des conserves
qui serait un petit peu plus ciblées
comme je disais pour doubler l'impact
général ya une forte générosité oui la
plupart du temps enfin la plupart du
temps les français sont généreux
donc on a cette chance là quand même
dans ce pays la collecte concrètement va
s'organiser sur quel site
alors là on sur le secteur il ya le
carrefour de saint quentin en yvelines
pour pour le week-end qui vient là et
puis le week-end prochain il y aura sur
elancourt
versailles pour les structures les plus
proches en tout 2000 familles qui sont
aidées par le secours populaire français
dans les yvelines est ce que c'est un
chiffre en évolution qu'elle nourrit
pour faire mais ça évolue
malheureusement j'ai toujours les mêmes
nouvelles à chaque fois que je reviens
sur votre plateau ça augmente tout le
temps mais c'est pas c'est pas de notre
faute
scherwiller oui la situation se
complexifie pour pas mal de nos
concitoyens et donc du coup il ya une
augmentation constante avec des publics
j'avais déjà vous évoquez me semble-t-il
quand il était venu sur le plateau qui
sont un petit peu nouveaux points qui
finissent par ne plus l'être
trop c des personnes qui vivent en hôtel
et mois de plus en plus en fait sur la
grande couronne francilienne donc faire
appel à vous deux mille familles en tout
chiffre en progression vous nous dites
je reviens juste à la collecte pour les
organiser faut des bénévoles
formellement et aujourd'hui il ya cette
bénévole bas on est jamais trop
c'est à dire que là par exemple sur
saint quentin en yvelines il va y avoir
une présence de 9h à 18h il ya un effet
d'entraînement c'est à dire qu' il ya
des bénévoles qui sont prévus pour pour
pour aider ça peut être aussi l'occasion
d'une première rencontre avec des
équipes du secours pour les personnes
qui cherchent des modalités pour
s'engager un petit peu plus sur la durée
et puis pour notamment le public jeune
qui a pas forcément beaucoup de
disponibilité pour venir régulièrement
dans les permanences d'accueil
rencontrer le public
une action collecte c'est un premier pas
qui peut compter et qui sera toujours
utile quoi donc c'est souple on peut
rester une heure comme la journée si on
a envie et en fait à peu près tout le
monde est bienvenu ce qu'ils ont envie
de dire tout le monde est bienvenu en
fait faut juste prévenir un peu avant
quand même pour qu'on sera pas surpris
le jour même et donc on invite les
personnes qui souhaiteraient participer
à cette action là sur les deux week-ends
à se rapprocher de la fédération on a un
numéro de téléphone c'est le 01 30 50 69
54 on appelle il ya une gentille dame
qui s'appelle alim qui va vous répondre
et qui va vous prendre vos inscriptions
vos horaires de disponibilité et ça se
fait aussi simplement vous laissera dire
le numéro chance le temps que les gens
de l'oeuvre qu'on puisse afficher 01 30
50 69 54
les bénévoles dans les yvelines ils sont
nombreux aujourd'hui combien combien
alors il n'y a plus de 1500 bénévoles
sur le département
alors dans le bénévolat s'il voulait il
ya des des profils
il ya des profils variable il ya des
gens qui aident très occasionnellement
sur des sur des fonctions très ciblée
voir saisonnières pour certains et puis
après il ya les gens qui sont très
réguliers très investis qui ont des
mandats bénévole dans l'association don
qu il ya un petit peu tous les profils
tous les âges
on peut commencer à être bénévole au
secours populaire à 6 ans après ça ne
s'arrête jamais on fait quoi à partir de
6 ans à partir de 6 ans on peut se
sensibiliser à la solidarité en
participant à des activités dans des
clubs de solidarité qu'on appelle
copains du monde on peut aussi
participer à des collectes dans son
école
on peut être acteur en proposant des
choses
y compris à ses parents et puis voilà
quoi c'est en fait chaque instant de la
vie peut être une occasion de se montrer
solidaires ou pas maintenant on insiste
plutôt sur le côté solidaire 2015 qui
débute dans un climat particulier juste
pour conclure vos attentes pour cette
pour cette année nous le secours
populaire on nous fait tous nos soixante
dix ans donc on souhaite que ça dure
au niveau de notre santé 70 ans encore
peut-être pas que la pauvreté se
développent pendant encore soixante dix
ans celle inverse mais en fait
l'émission s'élargissent de plus en plus
pour l'association et ça c'est un bon
c'est un bon signe je pense pour notre
société c'est à dire que à des moments
de crise plus ou moins sévères eh ben on
peut quand même aussi consacrer du temps
pour les autres de manière complètement
altruiste et désintéressé ça c'est une
valeur qu'il faut négliger donc scellé
souhait qu'on formule pour 2015 pour
2015 et pour vos 70 ans 20 70 ans du
secours populaire bien sûr merci pascal
rodier président dans les yvelines
mobilisation 17 et 24 janvier en tout
cas deux journées de collecte dans les
hypermarchés pour aider les familles qui
font appel à vous merci culture en
prémices du festival bd d'angoulême qui
des bars à partir du 29 janvier la
médiathèque jean rosso de guyancourt
oppose en ce moment une exposition
consacrée au super héros les images sont
signés patrick jacques de dixmude à la
médiathèque jean rousselot de guyancourt
les super héros sont de sortie pour une
exposition présentée jusqu'au 31 janvier
mais d'abord c'est quoi un super héros
super héros c'est quelqu'un qui est doté
de super pouvoirs et qui n'existe pas
dans la vie à elle mais avec auquel on
aimerait bien ressembler quelqu'un qui
est qu'est de la bravoure qui osent
défendre des autres qui m'ont qui
apporte des services qui aiment les
autres aussi du pain sur les planches
pourrait-on dire pour batman superman
wonder woman qui n'ont qu'à bien se
tenir
mais les super héros c'est aussi une
notion plus vaste le comics et le super
héros c'est des domaines qui sont des
fois moins connus -
- mis en avant en france peut-être dans
la bonne signer si la bande dessinée
américaine surtout et puis le héros le
super héros je crois que c'est des
choses qui sont d'actualité et on peut
être un héros très connu et un héros
anonymes
enfin la notion du héros elle est
intéressante je trouvais au 20e siècle
21e une notion d'autant plus forte en
cette période que le héros actuels
s'appelle la charly des affiches et des
panneaux pour expliquer le sens du super
héros des grandes firmes américaines aux
productions françaises c'est donc à
découvrir jusqu'au 31 janvier à la
médiathèque jean rousselot
en bonus une collection de bandes
dessinées et de figurines proposé par un
adhérent de la médiathèque
et puisqu'on parle de héros donc la
médiathèque jean rosselot à guyancourt a
souhaité rendre hommage à sa façon au
dessinateur de charlie hebdo en
affichant sur la façade de
l'établissement et des dessins en
reprenant d'anciennes une de
l'hebdomadaire satirique également des
dessins réalisés après les attentats du
7 janvier dernier que vous pouvez donc
découvrir actuellement sur la façade de
la médiathèque
et puis conséquence des tragiques
événements de ces derniers jours la
société jc decaux dont le siège se
trouve à versailles a refusé la
diffusion des affiches du dernier
spectacle de patrick timsit l'humoriste
il tient dans les bras une bombe
l'afficheur a expliqué que son comité de
déontologie avait estimé que cela
pouvait offusqué un grand public déjà
éprouvée par les attentats retour au
monde de la bande dessinée jusqu'au 31
janvier la médiathèque aimé-césaire à la
verrière propose de découvrir une
exposition autour des mangas à
l'occasion de découvrir les précurseurs
les séries cultes et les différentes
approches entre les pays asiatiques le
manga existe au japon depuis ya plus
d'un siècle
à noter pour les passionnés la
médiathèque contes 2242 ouvrage de manga
très exactement 24 janvier prochain
bruno rouane et animera un atelier de
création sur la bande dessinée de 15
heures à 17 heures et le 21 février
conférences et ateliers autour du manga
c'est à partir de 15h les renseignements
au numéro qui s'est affichée depuis une
semaine et jusqu'au 7 février la ville
de guyancourt propose de découvrir les
cosses avec une exposition itinérante
qui se déplacent chaque semaine sur
plusieurs maisons de quartiers de
l'agglomération à travers des
photographies le comité de jumelage de
la ville et des voiles paysage et moeurs
de sa ville jumelle lise gros lenice
bouet la ville est une ville écossaise
de hautes traditions l'écossé la nature
l'école c'est la vie c'est les lacs les
montagnes la neige
le but c'est de donner envie aux gens de
découvrir les causses et et peut-être de
venir avec nous dans lors de prochains
séjours l'essentiel des photos ce sont
les photos de nos adhérents qui sont
partis en voyage toutes ces années et
qui nous ont prêté gentiment ses poteaux
pour les exposer ainsi se termine ce
termine pardon ce journal prochaine
édition vendredi même heure pour
l'actualité du jour est l'essentiel de
la semaine comme chaque veille de week
end très bonne soirée